what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so the war of jokes and riddles is
amazing this story is incredibly good in
this video we're covering part one and
then we'll probably upload a second
video either later on today or later on
this week that will be part two the
conclusion of the whole thing but the
war of jokes and riddles is incredible
dare I say the best thing coming out of
DC rebirth right now it is probably one
of the best stories that that I've read
in a long time involving Batman but this
comes directly out of the aftermath of
zero year which we've covered and you'll
find that down in the Batman playlist in
the description what this also does is
it basically follows up to the idea that
Bruce Wayne has only been Batman for a
very short amount of time and so this
story is basically a retcon now for
those of you guys who were familiar with
comics and you know that is bear with me
for a second for the people who don't
reckon is basically it's it's short for
retroactive continuity and what it means
is that a writer will basically go back
to a particular character and put
something in their comics that wasn't
there before this is basically a story
that was never told before it was a set
of events that had never been hinted to
you we didn't know anything about it and
it's basically just throwing it in there
now saying this actually happened and
it's essentially a war between the Joker
and the Riddler and it is god it is
incredible so the cool thing is that
when it came to Batman zero year when it
came to like the origin of the Joker
different things like that the idea was
that it was telling the story of how the
Joker became the Joker but it fit in
with the notion of the fact that the
Joker is a guy that will always be one
of Batman's main villains if not his
most significant villain and so because
of that and following the events of zero
year the Joker had just sort of taken
off you know the guy who would become
the Joker eventually became the Joker
and then he would just fight Batman
later on what this does is it takes
place before a lot of the Joker stories
that we saw after zero year what it also
does is featuring you know kind of
talking about the Riddler for a second
the idea was that the Riddler was a
little more involved in a little more
complex and more developed in terms of
you know his storytelling now the reason
for this was simple the idea was that
when new 52 first launched and writer
Scott Snyder was basically crafting his
run on Batman the idea was to bring the
Joker back later on down the line during
death of the family technically speaking
death of the family is the first major
storyline that we see that features the
Joker when the new 52 first launched
back in 2011
following that was Batman in-game but
the idea was that because the Joker was
basically put on the back burner to be
used at a later date Snyder's sort of
focusing on things like the court of
owls and the night of owls and different
things like that two-face and Riddler
and so on and so forth so Riddler got a
lot more attention from Schneider and it
basically dealt with the idea of the
Riddler taking over Gotham City setting
up all these traps using the various
abilities of different villains and then
ultimately being caught and the mean
being arrested and thrown in jail the
cool thing about this is that Edward
nygma in a lot of ways I would say is
more dangerous than the Joker is the
reason for this is because of the fact
that yes the Joker is crazy and yes the
Joker zany and yes you never know what
he's gonna do
but Riddler is all about elaborate
schemes elaborate traps he may start a
sequence of events and the conclusion of
those events will not become readily
available or won't even be understood
until maybe months or even years after
they originally start and that's the
cool thing about him is because while
he's in jail what he actually starts
doing is making friends and talking to
people now it's really friends in the
sense of the fact that because he was so
good at figuring out puzzles and riddles
and so on that what he did is he became
a source for various cops who were
trying to figure out ways to solve
crimes that they could not solve on
their own and what it did it had been
kind of an essential figure in the sense
that a lot of cops began to get to a
point where they needed him one cop in
particular is basically killed by the
Riddler who in turn begins engineering
his own escape and that's kind of the
danger of it all is because what we end
up finding out is that one of the guys
the Riddler was talking to The Riddler
didn't ask for anything in particular he
wasn't asking for money he wasn't asking
for resources
he just wanted information about other
cops and the reason why is because when
he goes to make his escape he starts
running off the names of all these
different cops family members their
wives their children their son basically
being told the names of these people
which in turn he's going to use as part
of his plan worked perfectly for him
because he doesn't have to lift a finger
he doesn't have to shoot a person or
anything all he has to do is just say I
know who the people are that you care
about and bad things will happen to them
if you do not let me go and ultimately
that's exactly what they end up doing
they end up just stepping out of the way
they unlock the door and the Riddler
goes about his business now the other
half of this is the nature of the Joker
himself again because this takes place
after the events of the first zero year
story which dealt with you origin of the
Joker himself
is when he's full-on in the scene in
Gotham and so at this point people are
well aware of who he is but remember
Bruce Wayne has only been Batman for a
very short amount of time and so that
trust between society and Batman such as
it is has not really been built up yet
the other half of this is that because
they basically figure out the location
of where the Joker is what they end up
doing is basically blowing up his base
of operations just infiltrating the
place trying to take it down only to
realize the Joker's not there the
problem with this and the issue the drug
of the Joker struggles with is that he's
lost his ability to laugh not in the
literal sense it's more of a
metaphorical thing in the sense that the
Joker doesn't really find anything funny
anymore and so the goal is to basically
find something funny now what this does
is it sets the Joker on the path of
looking at Batman as a guy who's
basically the butt of every joke where
it basically begins the process of
pitting the two of them together about
how Batman needs the Joker the Joker
needs Batman that kind of a thing and
that's why it's cool is because at the
end of the day the Joker taking up
residence and do whatever it is he needs
to do and then ultimately he and the
Riddler encounter one another and the
proposition offered here by the Riddler
is pretty cool for them the idea of cops
being corruptible is a very simple thing
all you have to do is make enough money
to pay off cops and then those cops are
just sorted and that's it but Batman
cannot be bought you know he's not a
person that you can just go commit
crimes and then talk him out of
arresting you it doesn't really work
that way and so because of that the goal
is basically the two of them sitting
down and saying hey look we can make
something that's greater than the sum of
its parts
we can literally come together and we
can kill Batman when we do you get
whatever it is that you need that will
make you laugh I'll finally topple the
bats and we can just conquer the city
together and just rule it all together
the problem with this is that this feeds
into the unpredictability of the Joker
one of the things that makes the Joker
so dangerous is he is just as likely to
shoot you as he is to work with you and
in this instance Riddler doesn't know
what the Joker's gonna do there's no
predictability there there's no real
pattern there The Riddler says there is
when he basically says look I was able
to figure out you were the one that was
committing all these acts and I figured
out that you can't laugh because you
were basically killing comedians and you
were attacking places you were trying to
find a joke that you could laugh about
and you can find it but I can help you
solve this riddle ultimately the Joker
turns on Riddler actually just shoots
him and then is just done and that's
the problem with this is that remember
back during this point in his career of
being Batman Bruce Wayne was still very
very new to the whole thing he was still
very unsure of himself in a lot of
different ways he was still figuring it
all out in this instance he believes the
Joker to be more of a credible threat
than the Riddler also because the
Riddler was shot and it looks like he's
just gonna bleed out and die instead
because the fact that Batman goes after
the Joker the Riddler is able to escape
he's able to get away and so is the
Joker and so again that hits home at the
inexperience of Batman the fact that he
doesn't really know what road to taken
so ultimately this massive war breaks
out between the Joker in the Riddler
where various villains are essentially
forced to take sides now of course the
other half of this is that this also
comes out of the idea of Batman's
conversation with Catwoman in the sense
because of the fact that the two of them
are supposed to be getting married to
one another the question is will she
actually do it and is one of those
things where Batman's just kind of
dumping his heart out to the world and
telling her everything about himself his
deepest darkest secrets so that she goes
into a marriage with Batman basically
being sure of what it is she's getting
into and that's why it's cool because at
this point we basically continue to pick
up with the Joker and probably one of
his most ruthless moments now on the
surface it doesn't seem that ruthless it
doesn't seem that hardcore but he
actually ends up walking into a home
that currently belongs to a family that
templeton family walks into their home
and the Joker eliminates them all
literally takes them all out because
he's just trying to find something
that's funny the Riddler ends up coming
back I'm basically getting some surgical
work done by a disgraced doctor who had
long since lost his career but the other
half of this is the perception that it
gives us of the Joker in relation to how
the rest of the criminal empire views
him when the Joker calls up a guy by the
name of carmine infantino he basically
says look you have an hour to kill the
Riddler and if you don't do it bad
things are gonna happen and immediately
in Patino's on the job it has his guys
taking care of it he doesn't reluctantly
but he ends up doing it anyway because
he knows that the Joker will follow
through with his scheme this is
essentially a scenario where people are
just building up soldiers to their side
when it comes to the Riddler teaming up
with poison ivy this was already
established in zero year when he used a
lot of the things that she had to his
advantage in order to basically pull off
taking over Gotham a lot of the traps
and different things like that but when
infant he knows guys run up on Riddler
poison ivy they're taken out almost
right off the bat and so of course
because of that once in Pitino shows
back up and the Joker sitting in his
office and he says and hours passed and
the Riddler still alive we end up
finding out that the Joker had traveled
three hours to Metropolis to find the
mother of carmine infantino killed her
and then took all of her teeth out of
her mouth that was what he did in
response to Infantino not following his
directions like he said and that's why
people are so terrified of the Joker is
because of the lengths he will go to in
order to pursue his goal that's why he's
so dangerous and so ultimately with
Batman is simply discussing this whole
thing it turns into just this massive
war I mean on one side you have the
Riddler you've got you know Deathstroke
and you got to face and you have
scarecrow and you got Victor's eyes and
all these different guys and the sides
of the Joker
you've got Mr Freeze you've got Solomon
Grundy you got the Mad Hatter yeah
Deadshot you have these guys who are
basically criminals that just kind of go
about and they do their own things but
all these different villains that exist
in Gotham City are perfectly aware of
the fact that the Riddler in the Joker
are two of the most dangerous if not the
two most dangerous villains that exist
and so because of that they basically
fall rank-and-file they essentially
choose their sides with whoever it is
they think will ultimately win now the
other half of this is something this
does is it actually switches over to a
completely different guy a guy by the
name of kite man and kite man is the
best character ever
I love kite man hell yeah I love kite
man so much but he's got like this
saddest story ever know a little bit of
history here kite man goes all the way
back to 1960 with that man issue number
133 and he was really more of just like
a joke character that was created by
Bill Finger the idea was a kite man was
like the man who can fly anything is
really what it was and he would just
commit crimes by using contractions
largely associated with kites and then
that would just really be it he'd become
a Batman he'd get beat up and then he
would get thrown in jail or he wouldn't
have getting you know getting out he
played some roles here and there you
know he had involvement like Infinite
Crisis different things like that but
for the most part he was just this
background small-time joke character in
this particular story his origin is
traumatic and he's really this
incredibly interesting character because
the whole idea of the war of jokes and
riddles is not necessarily just the
Joker in
and riddle are going to war against one
another it's the people caught in the
middle and there have been a lot of
people caught in the middle of this
whole thing focusing more on the idea of
of Charles Brown the whole purpose of
this is that he's one of these guys who
had previously worked on the Joker
mobile for the Joker so he's got ties to
one of them already and in his
desperation Batman actually snatches him
up subdues him and then sends him in to
essentially spy on the Joker the problem
with this is that him spine is
immediately figured out by the Riddler
because of the fact that they have spies
on both sides I so brought before the
Riddler he basically spills the beans
he's eventually brought before the Joker
who figures out where he basically
explains everything that's going on and
so again it creates kind of a weird
scenario because ultimately when ends up
happening is we basically find out that
because the Riddler had realized that
Charles was basically a spy for Batman
going to work for the Joker and had
already been taken by the Riddler
ultimately the Riddler had actually
poisoned his son and so the result is
that he basically ends up losing his son
and that's what's so crazy is because
what this does is it unhinges him he's
not Joker crazy he's basically just sort
of lost his mind to a degree and so what
isn't happening is he actually just kind
of takes massive pieces of fabric starts
cutting them out into the shape of a
kite gives himself a body suit and then
just starts calling himself kite man and
so as funny as it is at the end of the
day it's basically this idea that he is
a guy who is really stuck in this
crossfire and experienced one of the
worst traumatic experiences that a
parent can ever have which is losing
their child the other half of this is
that will actually find out there's a
lot more going on with the creation of
his character than we originally thought
but with regards to the major event
itself the idea is that with
Commissioner Gordon looking at the fact
that you basically have the Upper East
Side the Upper West Side which have been
taken over by the Joker and the Riddler
the goal is to find a way to bring the
war to an end to basically preserve
Gotham City so nobody else has to
experience a casualty like this the
crazy thing about it is that when Jim
Gordon goes to meet with the Joker when
he goes to meet with the Riddler he's
given demands by both sides in terms of
how he's supposed to show up the Joker
just says show up in your underwear cuz
it's the Joker and when you're the Joker
that's what you do the Riddler is a lot
more complex as his character should be
now the cool thing about this is that
this is designed to display two
diametrically opposed asides and
juxtapose them next to
another the Joker is simple he's just a
crazy guy who wants to take out Batman
that's it
the Riddler is complicated he's
intriguing he's got all this lore and
all this mythology to him the other half
of this is that the war of jokes and
riddles is being fought on a
multi-faceted level you basically have
criminals fighting in the streets of
Gotham City in this instance it's
Deathstroke a genetically modified super
soldier against Deadshot who's just a
super accurate guy but because they're
the two greatest mercenaries in the
world their fight spans five days and 62
people die in the process so it is a
massive calamity between these guys
facing off against one another and it's
a pretty big deal at the end of the day
it all basically comes down to Batman it
comes down to him as a character having
to figure out a way to end this war
knowing that it's not gonna stop into
the Joker or the Riddler achieve their
goal of essentially taking him out and
now the cool thing about this is that
because Batman has the Wayne family
fortune at his disposal what he actually
does is he orchestrates a sit-down
between the Riddler and the Joker it's
basically just them bickering with each
other the whole time if just thinking
potshots and like the Riddler making fun
of him and in that kind of a thing but
it's interesting to see this happen
because it goes down exactly as we would
expect in this sense did they just sort
of argue and carry on different things
like that but it's basically them making
the case as to why it is that they
should be the one to take down Batman
and that's the proposal that Bruce Wayne
offers here again they don't know that
Bruce Wayne is Batman they have no idea
that the two of them are the same person
and so going through and basically
pretending as though he doesn't care
about the Batman concept he doesn't care
whether Batman lizard eyes that his
loyalty is directly to Gotham City
itself he basically says both of you
guys make your arguments on who it is
you think should win and I'll give a
billion dollars to the winner and that
will allow them to pay off all the
criminals in Gotham City pay off the
cops do whatever as they need to do in
order to basically take out Batman
and it's kind of crazy because of what
we end up finding out is that prior to
this sit-down the Joker and the Riddler
had basically both brought in hostages
under the idea that if something were to
happen to them the hostages would be
killed
what is up happening is the Joker agrees
to free his hostages and the Riddler
believes he killed his before he showed
off
which he did it's pretty I mean it's not
funny but it's it's it's pretty it's
messed up me it's pretty messed up it's
kind of rough but but the fact remains
here that it is interesting to me
because again it really hits home with
the notion that Bruce Wayne is having to
do a lot of things that he never thought
he would when it came to the character
of Batman the idea was to basically be a
guy who could essentially walk the
middle ground he could walk the middle
line where he was basically always doing
the right thing he'd have to make some
questionable choices here and there but
there would be the good guys and the bad
guys and the cool thing about the whole
war of jokes and riddles story so far is
that what it shows us is the lengths
that Batman has to go to from now on you
know to basically be the guy that could
take out the criminals is he will have
to become the antihero who will have to
blur the lines that sometimes he's going
to have to make questionable choices
that will force him to ask the question
am I really a good guy so that's kind of
the crazy thing about this and one of
the major choices that he makes is he
sits down and he says if I have to pick
a winner and if I have to bring this war
to an end and the only way to stop it is
to basically take out one of these guys
then which guy do i side with he
basically makes the smarter choice and
sides with the Riddler because the Joker
is so far gone in a lot of different
ways because he's just so crazy
Batman were to take up sides with the
Joker then the Joker may very well just
kill him at this point you know the
Riddler and the Joker both won a win so
it's really one of those things worse
like the enemy of my enemy is my friend
but there's no guarantee the Joker would
see it that way if the Joker and the
Riddler are at war with one another and
their ultimate goal is to take out
Batman but in the short term goal is to
take out the other person the Joker may
bypass all that the Joker may say well I
mean the ultimate goal is to take out
Batman so I'm just gonna take him out
and be done and that's it you know and
then whatever happens happens that's the
crazy thing but the Riddler is a lot
more fluid in his thought analytical in
terms of how he looks at things the
Riddler's immediate goal is to take out
the Joker after which then he'll focus
on Batman and so because of that Batman
sides with the Riddler it's just the
smarter choice to make now the other
half of this is also using the resources
of the kite man against both Joker and
Riddler using kites to fly into where
the where the Joker is at and then in
turn in the middle of a whole conflict
once the Joker's temporarily defeated
and the most logical thing happens when
criminals of the Riddler turn against
Batman he basically set things up so
that kite man could modify the PAC's
kick him into action and they would
basically yank the criminals out of
Gotham City into the air where they be
swooped up by Alfred in the batboy
because apparently the that blimp is
still a thing but the idea here is that
this ultimately boils down to the Joker
and the Riddler fighting against Batman
but the crazy thing about this is that
this is essentially everything Bruce
Wayne has been talking about when he's
been going through and recounting this
entire story - Selina Kyle take Catwoman
basically saying this is where I
committed the act that I swore I never
would have committed before we end up
finding out that in the middle of this
conflict the only option Batman feels he
has in order to successfully take out
the Riddler is to kill him and that's
exactly what he ends up doing he harkens
back to the idea of the Riddler killing
kite man's son he harkens back to the
idea that this war has cost so many
lives and has seemingly been pointless
and in that anger in that wrath while he
is of clear and sound mind he takes the
action of trying to kill the Riddler now
that's huge for Batman because it'd be
different a Batman just let himself go
right like if he just acting out of rage
and wasn't thinking clearly and had a
temporary moment of insanity and what to
go tell the Riddler that would make a
lot more sense for the Batman character
in terms of fans letting it slide I mean
Batman fans will let Batman get away
with anything but in terms of you know
people looking at it and saying okay
this is not something Batman normally
should have done him being of clear and
sound mind shows us how far and how fast
he was able to fly but again it really
hits back home to the nature of the fact
that he's inexperienced because Batman
as we know him now which is to say if
you go crack open a story from DC
rebirth and you read I am Bane or
something along those lines
Batman is calm he's almost in complete
and total control of his faculties and
he never allows himself to get carried
away with wrath or anger and if he does
it's momentary it's never a major thing
in this instance he's still young he's
still reckless allowing himself to get
carried away falls in perfectly with the
idea that he's still trying to figure
out his place in this whole pantheon of
superheroes in the DC Universe in
relation to all the criminals that exist
in Gotham City trying to kill the
Riddler is a pretty big deal because
what is up happening is the Joker
actually gets in his way and the Joker
stops him and in his insanity finds the
whole thing hilarious but that's what's
crazy about it is because the Joker
stopped Batman from killing the Riddler
and that's nuts it's it's it's wild to
really think about it that way that the
Joker was the thing that kept Batman
from falling over the edge now this hits
home with the nature of the Joker
it's a well-established fact the Joker
needs Batman he needs to have him there
he needs to keep him there that's what
makes sense that he would go that length
but spilling all these beans - Selina
Kyle basically telling her that he
allowed himself to fall to that point
where he almost became the villain that
kills people he also mainly ends up
saying look if we're gonna do this you
have to know what you're getting into
I've fallen before I've made that
mistake but Selina Kyle's argument is
everyone has the fact that you did this
all it does is it makes you human
you get carried away you get angry you
get sad you get filled with emotion just
like anybody else it's not a failing
it's the fact that you recognize that
you fell that makes you great because it
means that you know where you can get
down to and you don't want to be there
anymore and that's why it's cool is
because it's her saying if you get to
that point if you feel yourself slipping
then I will be your guide I will be the
anchor by which I can pull you from the
bottom of this ocean of despair and I
can bring you back to the light and so
when the questions asked will you marry
me
Selina Kyle says yes so it's so cool
because we're gonna see that man and
Catwoman get married so I'm really
excited about this there's gonna be one
heck of a ride it's gonna be a pretty a
pretty awesome thing but that being said
guys we're gonna bring this thing to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain to make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
cork if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you